hello everyone and welcome to today's
live webinar understanding and
ameliorating radiation induced damage to
oligodendrocyte presented by dr.
Alexandra terrible Eddie
I'm Christy Jolla flat boots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
educational web seminar is presented by
laberd's and brought to you by thermo
Fisher Scientific to learn more about
our sponsor please visit thermo Fisher
com forward slash cell culture heroes
now let's get started today's webinar is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them in the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation just use the ask a question
box to let us know you're having a
problem
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation just let us know you're
having a problem by using the ask a
question box
this presentation is educational and the
software's continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab and follow the process to
obtain your credits and now present
today's speaker dr. Alexandra terrible
Letty postdoctoral fellow Georgetown
University for a complete biography on
our speaker please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen
you're terrible Eddie you may now begin
your presentation
James Christie for that great
introduction
you so much for hosting me as the good
Cosell culture hero today I hope to host
a really accessible talk that covers the
basics of white matter damage from
radiation therapy with the title
understanding and ameliorating radiation
induced damage to oligodendrocyte and
also going through how I use cell
culture and metabolomic to better
understand this issue but before I dive
into this topic let me first tell you a
little bit about myself
ah my buckler's is actually in chemistry
I've kind of journeyed a far away I got
my bachelor's at University of Central
Florida and I started in all things in
material science where I did the can of
chemistry doping materials with cathode
luminescence properties tangentially I
also worked with crickets of all things
so if anyone ever needs to respect for
cricket I'm that person I use these to
look at temperature changes in respect
to global warming so again very diverse
background but the chemistry and the
biology led me to go into biochemistry
my PhD is in metabolomic and
neurobiology technically my degree is in
chemistry from the University of Akron
but I looked at global metabolomics and
I investigated glial metabolism which
I'll kind of get into the glial part a
little more here soon but generally I
looked at your degenerative diseases
treatment of neurodegenerative diseases
and analyzing the metabolic products of
some of the oligodendrocyte
now I
a post doctoral candidate has a
postdoctoral fellowship at Georgetown
University and I study radiation
metabolomics one of my projects in
particular is actually distinguishing
metabolic biomarkers for radiation
injury this was looking at a
pre-processing approach for ionizing
radiation injury so we were able to pick
out biomarkers that allowed us to
indicate injury and made a type of
extraction that's useful for an event a
radiological event to pick out injury
markers but today I am going to talk
about the marriage of all of my fields
of interests and knowledge those again
being the central nervous system damage
radiation injury and then using the
catalytic as well to kind of talk about
all of these
from this overview you should find the
intersection of all three of those
knowledge branches as we discuss again
understanding and ameliorating the
radiation damage that occurs in brain
oligodendrocyte following cancer
radiation therapy using the technique of
metabolomic
some of their learning objectives for
this talk that I hope you'll gain is
just a general understanding of the
current state and brain radiation
treatment patient outcomes and their
quality of life stuff all of therapy you
think this is important to always bring
it back and think about patients
I went to detail basic squeal cell
biology and how I use the mo 313 cell
line to model these immature I'm mature
differentiated oligodendrocyte so
they're kind of the bread and butter of
my work and also understanding mass
spectrometry base metabolomic and how we
can use it to monitor markers of
radiation entry and alleged that mistake
metabolism in subculture
so first I'm going to start with going
into understanding the brain radiation
treatment
so to talk about lady
damage I first have to talk about cancer
cancers of the CMS include cancers that
affect the brain the spinal cord and
also the cranial nerves today I'm going
to focus mostly on talking about the
brain primary central nervous system
cancers can derive from different cell
lineages these include characters like
gliomas after Civic tumors and elyda
been gurgly all tumors and also in
medulloblastomas tumors can also start
in another part of the body and
metastasize to the brain these tend to
be the most difficult to manage cancers
and the most dangerous they are also
more common than the primary tumors that
I previously mentioned
options for any type of CNS whether it
be a cancer that has metastasized or a
primary tumor include things like
surgery that's when possible to resect
it from the brain you can do a complete
or partial resection of the tumor
chemotherapy as well so Kim therapeutic
drugs but these aren't used very often
because it's difficult for many to cross
the blood-brain barrier and get into the
drug into the brain excuse me
and then lastly is radiation which is
what's commonly used you can penetrate
the brain from the exterior you don't
have to worry about the blood-brain
barrier and there's no complexities of
surgery
radiation treatment consists of the
conventional therapy which uses an
external beam it can be beam of x-rays
gamma rays or protons and this depends
on the type of cancer it also actually
depends on the facility and in some
cases it depends on what country you're
in some countries only will allow
certain types of ionizing radiation this
includes things like even carbon which I
believe is not currently being utilized
in the United States right now but
generally you use CT scanning to kind of
get an idea of rona targets a tumor and
then the ionizing beams are aimed at the
tumor to kill the cancer cells and to
shrink the tumor the therapy is usually
given over a period of several weeks so
it's fractionated meaning multiple doses
over time and the actual area that
receives radiation treatment may be
large or small meaning a small area of
the brain or a large area of the brain
and that again depends on the type of
cancer
radiation treatment is usually limited
to what we call partial brain
irradiation when possible but whole
brain radiation is also common when
presented especially with metastatic
cancer in the brain
so again metastatic cancer which is news
from another place usually tends to form
multiple areas of tumor instead of one
singular tumor and those are harder to
singularly target so a whole brain
radiation hoping is used preferentially
in this case whole brain treatment has
widespread effects of you might death
instead of targeting one single area
you're just for radiating the whole
brain so it causes more severe damage
and it also particularly impacts these
stem cell populations in the brain which
is a real danger
so some of the injuries that have been
documented and occur in stages that are
from radiation therapy start with acute
injury and these can be things as simple
as headaches and drowsiness and then you
kind of early delayed effect where the
myelination has been documented
you see attention deficit and short-term
memory loss and then late documented
injuries include vascular abnormalities
again the myelination and the brain loss
of the brain cells Oakley OSIS and the
most dangerous cognitive impairments
this is general cognitive impairment
seen over a long time and this leads to
poor quality of life and patients
so currently there is a limited focus on
kind of ameliorating or stopping the
damage caused by radiation therapy which
again leads to this poor patient quality
of life when you have severe cognitive
effects these are just worries I'm
saying but as a reminder I've talked to
patients that are involved with therapy
I've spoken with advocates and those who
have survived in a lot of the focus of
course is put on survival the cancer but
now a lot of these patients now that
they're surviving they suffer cognitive
impairment which again hasn't really
been focused on so that's my goal of
this study
both of these injuries include the
radiation in this injury to children so
a large study was done by King at all
that looked at children who received
radiation therapy for cancer treatment
when they were young of course and into
adulthood these children unfortunately
had declining IQs if they received
radiation treatment versus if they did
not receive this whole brain radiation
treatment
studies have also shown this cognitive
impairment after whole brain radiation
and adults as well so the screen officer
at all also denotes that increasing
after months of whole grain irradiation
you see almost a 85% of the population
having cognitive impairment and again
this is after whole brain irradiation
one of the markers of this cognitive
impairment that was previously mentioned
and tied to the memory problems and
again cognitive impairment has to do
with demyelination or loss of white
matter white matter is just a type of
matter within the brain you have gray
matter regions and white matter region
this the myelination is marked in animal
models and also in humans as well here
you can see from one of my studies
this is decreased staining in the corpus
callosum the stain stands for white
matter this is seven days after seven
gray of extra radiation the corpus
callosum in particular which I'm
standing is an area that's rich rich
white matter area and excuse me let's
went to farther
you can see again denoted in a mouse
model markers of white matter cells that
are lost from one day to 15 months after
radiation
you see both two markers is o4 and MVP
marker which drastically decreased after
radiation
and to confirm in humans as well tissue
from humans these again are markers of
white matter cells again you see this to
myelination that's persistent and this
marker seems to go along with the
cognitive decline they're just giving
the importance buttons is myelination
and white matter loss is connected to
the cognitive decline that you see in
patients
together a grasp on radiation induced
damage in the brain you focus on this
white matter damage and again its
connection to a cognitive impairment so
we model the radio sensitive cells that
actually make up the white matter this
is what our lab focuses on are the cells
of the white matter and their connection
to this cognitive impairment
which brings us
kind of our second learning objective
which is talking about glial biology
these cells of the brain and how we use
the mo 313 cell wine to model immature
and mature differentiated alleged
interface
so the brain is not just made up of
neurons cells though they're very
important they're important for signal
transduction and memory there are other
glial cells with all them glial cells
that make up a bulk of brain tissue and
these include things like astrocytes
these are important for structure and
metabolic support of neurons and also
the glial cell microglia and these are
actually the specialized immune cells of
the brain and lastly and my favorite of
course is the alleged under sight these
cells protect the neuronal axon and they
help facilitate the signal that's
transferred through neurons so they act
kind of like the insulation on a wire
and they also serve to have a metabolic
purpose so they metabolically serve in
your lines as well a lot of important
rules
these cells they wrap their cell
membrane around neuron around the axon
you can kind of see in this picture here
the spiral wrapping to form what we call
myelin so just the wrapping of the
membrane around the neuron is called
myelin and white mountain regions in the
brain which we're interested in are
highly concentrated with myelinated
neurons so more generally saying these
areas are areas with more
oligodendrocytes cell which is why we're
focused on the oligodendrocyte cells
they kind of barred the cell of the
white matter so the depth of
oligodendrocytes cells is what causes
demyelination
so what we were talking about before and
the de myelination pattern that causes
that white matter loss and radiation
injury and is connected to the cognitive
impairment that worried about impatient
so our lab is just
in kind of examining these
oligodendrocyte self
hoog identify those i noted are also a
metabolic support for neuron they
support a lot of the metabolic demands
for neuron through production of things
like pyruvate this n acetyl aspartate or
naa and other small molecule metabolites
the myelin sheath itself which again has
just the membrane of the alleged vendor
site which wraps around the neuron is
formed highly eclipsed and it also has a
very high energy cost to make all of
those lipids and wrap them around the
neuron so these cells themselves are
very vulnerable to energy depletion
you
only good under cite cells also start as
a stem progenitor state which is called
the oligodendrocyte progenitor cell or
you'll see OPC and they mature to the
final version which is the myelinating
version of the version that actually
wrapped itself around the neuron so pcs
or stem cells are more vulnerable to
oxidative stress and damage from
radiation but the mature cells are
harder to regenerate once lost the kind
of maintaining the balance of these
populations is key to the healthy white
matter and also understanding how both
of these populations act in radiation is
also important
so to do this returning to a cell line
and the advantages of an oligodendrocyte
cell line as opposed to using a primary
culture again it's a simple system you
have reproducibility when you have a
cell line and very controlled condition
and in particular for when we're doing
mass spec analysis you can isolate
individual metabolic creatures which
again is very key we're very focused on
how specifically the oligodendrocyte
show is reacting to radiation and not
necessarily after sites or microglia or
neurons so those are all important and
the components of each of those and
their metabolic interests are also
important we want to first start with
isolating what is making the
oligodendrocytes Alki looking at
the singular cell also has a less
complex matrix which is good for most
ecology and we're using a cell line you
have the ability to collect high cell
count which as opposed to primary cells
is they're a bit harder to culture and
to get going
permaculture machine you need a lot of
cells and so the cell line approach in
this case is very useful
so our lab uses and has developed the
model at the end or 313 cell line which
we use in dmem with x12 it is a human
oligodendrocyte cell line here's what it
looks like
this Ally and one of the nice things
about it is that you're able to look at
both immature states or more like the
OPC state and the mature state of the
cell so it has this tunable advantage
and you differentiate it simply by using
PMA added to the media
here you can see the immature versus the
differentiated state they both produce
markers of the oligodendrocytes but you
can see that their membranes kind of
drastically change you also see if you
look to the right they are expressing
this myelin basic protein which is MVP
more highly expressed in the
differentiated state and that's
associated with the myelin forming sheep
the first time we've also used this cell
line to model radiation injury so here
you can see the cell line in a champagne
this is receiving no radiation versus
when undergoing for gray of x-ray this
is about seven days post the extra
radiation that prolific of capacity
decreases with increasing radiation and
you can see that these cells they
apoptosis generally they hold position
and they kind of flatten out this is
comparable to what primary cells do as
well so this model for first time we've
shown comfortably modeled radiation
injury in a cell line just like how it
is models in primary
so to recap we've talked about radiation
therapy and how it can cause long-term
damage to white matter and cognitive
decline without damaged white matter is
composed of radiation sensitive
oligodendrocyte cells and how the mo
3:13 cell line can be used to model the
radiation damage to a look at Isis
itself so with youth of this MOA 13
model in hand and you can begin to
explore the impact of radiation on a
liquid under state function and its
metabolism the number of these are
metabolically active cells so
understanding their metabolism is very
important and also to model mode of
protection this is a great model to test
out therapeutics it's again very
important to understand how the
oligodendrocytes bioenergetic regulates
normal brain function and how this
dysfunction contributes to the end
demyelination
that brings us to kind of our last
talking point which is understanding
mass spectrometry based metabolomic and
it's used in recipes in monitoring the
markers radiation injuries and a look at
under psych and capitalism
on the cellular level radiation causes
this oxidative damage that starts an
inflammatory cascade in town and that
leads to cell death which then causes
the denomination or white matter loss
and potential long term cognitive
impairment and again oligodendrocytes
are very susceptible to metabolic or
oxidative changes in this include
radiation seems to be why they are the
most sensitive of the glial cells and
the brain
so to monitor the oscillating metabolism
of the oligodendrocyte cell in response
to damage we use this technique
metabolomic and the table makes is a
technique that can monitor all small
molecule metabolites which are just law
molecules so things like glucose or
tryptophan or serotonin all these
neurotransmitters any small molecule and
the difference of metabolomics and the
importance of it
is that the information is phenotypic
and this is as opposed to things like
genomics which is measuring at a genome
level or transcriptome extra proteomics
this is a this is phenotypic information
and it also gives you kind of an
instantaneous snapshot of the cell
metabolism which makes it very useful
for temporal studies as well
so mass spectrometry metabolomic is
utilized via two main approaches which
are targeted versus untargeted
approaches and again this useful for
monitoring the injury that occurs in
these oligodendrocytes oh so in an
untargeted technique you take your
tissue or cell in this case and then
you're going to detect all of the
metabolites that are there and then we
do what's called statistical reduction
and identification so we identify all of
these Peaks we get into actual compound
so we identify them as things like
serotonin or tryptophan etc and then we
have to do a validation step as well
just to validate we check it against a
standard and then a targeted approach
instead of collecting everything you're
going to calibrate the machine to the
metabolites of interest so they're only
interested in neurotransmitters and
you're only interested in things in the
tryptophan pathway then you would do a
targeted approach and similarly now the
machines just calibrated to the news and
tabloids interest you detect those of
interest and you can quantify how much
of that metabolites such questions so
macabre omics kind of has endless
application in this case you usually are
doing untargeted techniques to start
with is to look at what's happening in
the cell and then from there we move to
the targeted approach in which now we
kind of have an idea of what we're
interested in and so we target and
quantify those small molecules in the
cell
so in
our work we've utilize metabolomic to
analyze the capacity of drugs to
ameliorate the inflammatory damage
really good understate again it's
important that we're using this cell
line paired with metabolomic to be able
to monitor these drugs capacity to kind
of stop inflammatory cascade generally
use the idea of these projects is to
induce oxidative stress and inflammation
this can be from radiation of course but
we can also monitor other ways of
oxidative stress it has an example one
of the drugs that we're looking at is
this dimethyl fumarate or DMF compare it
to vehicle
doing a comparative analysis
and we use mass spectrometry again this
mass spectrometry based metabolomics and
we're able to analyze all of the
inflammatory molecules and all the
changes and small molecules that occur
whether we give a protective drug versus
vehicle
so in this example that I've shown
pretreatment with DMS actually altered
the TCA cycle which is a important
metabolic cycle in the oligodendrocytes
and an increased agency malate
boomer 8 and flexin 8 this is
specifically with pretreatment of the
drug and metal-free might I be up to 72
hours of pretreatment gave you the most
increase in this TCA cycle the Tapley
and this is important because as I keep
skating oligodendrocyte have high
metabolic demands and these TCA
intermediates are crucial to its
function
you can see kind of the positive impact
of the drug using tableau mix on the
cell line you also see the protection
through up regulation of glutathione
again if you just pretreat this the drug
you've shown that there's increased
reduced glutathione levels there's a
antioxidant molecule I'm stopping to
decrease the oxidation that could occur
from radiation and kind of prepare
yourself for oxidative damage and we
showed that when you pretreat the cells
the pms as our metabolomics led us to
believe this increase in antioxidants
also led to protection of self when
they're treated for up to $70 fire with
a drug from oxidative damage in this
case shown here published is when they
were treated with hydrogen peroxide
which is just another inflammation
inducing treatment
he then leads of course to look at
radiation now that we kind of had an
idea that using the tablets in their
cell line we could see protection and
over time there was an initial boost
again in tumor 8 succinate and malate
from the drug dimethyl fumarate when
used pretreatment but it decreased
generally after radiation energy however
you can see that the levels of the
antioxidant glutathione the reduced
glutathione actually stays constant
throughout up to 72 hours after
radiation this again kind of shows the
power of the time to monitor these
temporal changes and small molecules and
to like it interstate metabolism in this
response to radiation injury
and complemented by
metabolic data you see that pretreatment
of this p.m. EMF actually decreases
cellular apoptosis following the X
irradiation at for gray so decrease cell
death or a loss of a look at under site
so let me kind of models a candidate
drug which is DMF that can ameliorate
the damage of these white matter or get
on the site and we did this using mass
spectrometry based metabolomic paired
with our mo 313 ly
the information we
therapy can cause long-term damage to
white matter and cognitive decline and
damaged white matter is composed of
these radiation sensitive alleged
endocytic well the mo 3:13 tell line
which I've shared you can be used as a
good model for radiation damage to
oligodendrocytes though and is well
paired with mass spectrometry based
metabolomics to help model products of
radiation injury in oligodendrocytes
I've also shown you kind of a case study
in which we showed that dimethyl
fumarate can offer protection to magenta
sites through metabolic alterations
so I'm so thankful to be again the
chosen four as a good curved cell
culture hero and I'm thankful to
everyone that I've worked with at
Georgetown University in my tumor
biology program at the University of
Akron where I started my PhD and for all
the fun things that has supported me as
well
and with that thanks for listening and I
want to open it up to any questions
Thanks
you
thank you doctor terrible lighting for
your informative presentation we will
now start the live Q&A portion of our
webinar now if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we will
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for okay let's get started we
have some great questions coming in dr.
terrible Eddie what exactly is a
mechanism of action for DMF oh great
question thanks Christy
so DMF is let me start actually already
a known drug that's being used it's a
nerve protectant it's I'm actually using
it to as a repurposing drug so it's FDA
approved and use of multiple sclerosis
its mechanism of action is actually to
target nrf2 which then leads to the up
regulation of glutathione which is one
of the reasons they're looking at
glutathione production
thank you now next question how could
these therapeutics be used for patients
receiving radiation therapy okay so as
an actual application for the
therapeutics because most of our work
was looking at a protective effect that
occurred prior when treated prior to
radiation this would be a type of drug
that would be given to patients who
again are going to be going in for
radiation treatment and therapy prior
about 72 hours prior to the actual
radiation that they would receive and
then help hopefully give a protective
effect
now are there any feel any other fields
in this research that have application
to outside of cancer therapy yeah so one
that I would any occupational field that
in which people are receiving radiation
and potentially could receive radiation
to the brain these are also a great area
to study for protection and those of us
one thing that I'm passionate about
because I'm actually a big space nerd
and my parents were that not so when I
was young so one area that's being Ward
also for these types of protections is
for astronauts that are going to go to
Mars they're going to need protection
from radiation as well
we've got some great questions coming in
let's go with this next one why would
you use targeted versus untargeted mass
spectometry
in your site okay so I kind of touched
on this as far as like right untargeted
and targeted is untargeted being you're
using an exploration of all metabolites
but it's not semi quantitative upon't
truly quantitative in that respect so if
you want to actually get a quantitative
metabolites that you're looking at or
how much in a simple drug how much are
there you'd want to use a targeted
experiment it's also just more sensitive
so kind of once you know what you're
looking for in this case I kind of
understood that PCA molecules are being
change or changing in Miami physics in
cells using an untargeted first let's
have a wellness experiment and then I
shifted over to targeted now that I know
what I'm looking for and I can actually
see how much is there thank you dr.
terrible Eddie now what metabolites do
you see in this inflammatory cascade
uh in the in signatory cascade so in
this particular cell line and again this
is because it and in our f2 targets this
I am looking at glutathione production
but much of the work in my lab has been
directed at this inflammatory cascade
that happens with radiation in general
and not necessarily in relation to gbms
as a protectant and so in that case you
would see some of the more standard
inflammatory molecules and the worsening
I suggest that you you check out the
foreign a slab and see kind of what
they're working on
thanks doctor terrible Eddie now we're
almost up out of time this will have to
wrap with this question what do you must
be protective with grade 3 to 4 brain
tumors at a 60 gray ir um that's a good
question this is far kind of in the
future as far as patients that would be
looking at I have looked at this in
respect to glioblastoma which is a very
aggressive brain tumor and there have
been actually some patient studies that
have looked at DMS not as in or
protective but actually against as an
anti-cancer agent as you say and in that
case it didn't work as an anti-cancer
agent they did see some protection I
don't know about at the 60 gray on my
end and my research of just because we
haven't tested at that amount I ideally
right now we're mimicking in mice which
isn't an exact model the amount of
radiation they would receive for a
glioblastoma treatment but I haven't
tested it at that high of radiation
thank you doctor terrible Eddie don't
you have any final comments for our
audience
um I just want to give us thanks again
Thank You Chrissy thanks to gecko in
general for letting me be to talk it's
been a really great experience and of
course if anyone has further questions
you want to reach out to me feel free to
look at my website at a star bloody comm
or you can find me all over Twitter as
well
science Twitter birth thank you again
now we'd like to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions again just a
reminder that the questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by our speakers we have the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration thank you again to
dr. Alexander terrible Eddie for her
time today and her important research
with like to thank elaborate and also
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinth will alert you via email when
it's time for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and we hope to see
you again soon have a great day